[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous merci d'être venus
bonjour à vous donc bienvenue pour cette
table ronde s'exprimer même si on n'a
rien à dire un effet pervers des réseaux
sociaux
donc pour discuter de cette passionnante
question nous avons avec nous un créatif
bonjour monsieur ça au mr sam comment
alors mais je me suis gouré en fait
parce que normalement si tu mets est
mère tu mets pas de points et si tu
m'aimes tu mets un point donc je me suis
emmerdé sur mon pseudo donc c'est
monsieur au mr sam c'est comme vous
voulez comme vous voulez et astrologique
merci alors pour commencer je vous
propose que chacun présente un peu sa
chaîne succinctement n'empêche qu'ils
sont chaud dans la salle je crois qu'il
n'est pas une pareille en oeuvre les
autres échaudés un créatif oui donc j'ai
une chaîne qui parle de marketing
globalement je décrypte les stratégies
des marques surtout dans le but de faire
50 % de l'humour et à 50% on va dire la
sensibilisation la cotisation de la
prévention et ce genre de choses et je
suis belge c'est vrai oui monsieur mr
j'ai dû faire moins de route pour venir
quoi monsieur mr sam j'aime beaucoup
moi j'ai une chaîne de pensée critique
philo des sciences épistémologie tous
ces trucs là où je parle un petit peu
d'effets que news je parle un peu de
science je parle un petit peu des trucs
je met les mains dans des choses qu'on
n'a pas l'habitude de d'apprendre à
connaître comme la terre plate
qu'est ce qu'on pense vraiment quand on
est plate east c est le tout avec une
petite pointe d'humour non dissimulé
exactement les mêmes mots et je suis
belge
merci l'humour ne gâche jamais rien sur
astronomiques
oui si tu aime l'humour oui nos tâches
est alors moi c'est arnaud thierry alias
astronomiques et comme le pseudo lundi
qu'au moins je l'espère j'essaye de
parler d'astronomie sur ma chaîne mais
comme l'astronomie est aussi un sujet
qui est souvent un terreau fertile pour
les complots et connerie en tous genres
dans ce style là eh bah je me suis
souvent retrouvé amené à moi aussi
devoir parler un petit peu de je vais
dire d'esprit critique
ouais genre on est allé oui comme tu dis
on est genre allez faire des crop circle
vous en avez peut-être entendu parler
ça marche et donc pour ma part je modère
ray cette table-ronde je suis valentine
de la chaîne sciences de comptoir sur
laquelle on peut apprendre à lécher ou à
rayer des cailloux excellent enchaîne
donc pour parler des réseaux sociaux et
bien parlons des réseaux sociaux quels
réseaux sociaux vous utilisez-vous et
lesquels vous préféré et pourquoi
et sinon monsieur crête
ok oui oui alors en temps en temps au
tour de ma chaîne on va dire pas
personnellement mais autres la chaîne
celui qui utilise le plus en dehors de
youtube en excès de twitter pour deux
raisons simples la première personnel
c'est juste ça peut manger bien celui
sur lequel plus je suis plus à l'aise
parce que je suis plus à l'aise avec le
fait de tweets et que par exemple je
bats à produire des photos sur instagram
et ce genre de choses et j'aime bien
l'aspect pour moi c'est le réseau auquel
cas le potentiel le plus viral on peut
se dire que contrairement à des réseaux
comme facebook instagram extra qui sont
très fermes et dire qu'on reste dans
très difficile d'étendre de faire en
sorte que quelqu'un vienne de nulle part
et ajuste dessus et tout d'un coup ça
amène toute une autre audience il ya un
côté hyper hyper viral sur twitter où on
passe au quelqu'un de rendre un peu post
peut tuer quelque chose ensuite
quelqu'un qui n'en a la chance de venir
répondre qui va amener plein de vie vite
et ça se passe très vite
énormément de choses et j'aime bien cet
aspect de twitter donc quand tu dis
aspect général parce que derrière
derrière ça ton but c'est de te faire
connaître quel et quel est ton objectif
quand tu twittes adducteurs je le vois
comme comme une annexe comme un
complément sterger pas l'occasion de te
régulier sur la chaîne extra par contre
je suis naturellement beaucoup
une fois toutes les une heure ou deux
secondes et oui voilà j'ai bien c'est
devenu une habitude
je réfléchis pas qui est là je pense moi
je considère que c'est une manière
d'entretenir on va dire le locker engagé
la communauté on va dire qu'il ya 10% de
la chaîne qui sont sur twitter et c'est
la partie la plus engagée et j'ai du
coup ça permet de s'entretenir en voilà
effectivement une relation avec
l'audience au quotidien que je peux pour
entretenir via la chaîne où là c'est
plutôt des voilà des grands en a qui
viennent tous les x temps pour manière
plus le plus large quoi pour moi je les
vois vraiment complémentaires ou
complément à la troisième raison
simplement aussi que c'est les réseaux
qui pendant le plus lié à un youtube
c'est le meilleur qu elle pour se
développer voilà globalement oui je suis
assez à l'aise avec bayard ton à
l'univers que j'aime bien dans twitter
il ya un mode qui me qui me parle j'ai
pas le seul quand même si qui parmi vous
et sur twitter
alors je suis pas très bonne pour
compter mais je dirais qu'à peu près
deux millions de main levée à peu près
s'écroule quand tu disais entre
entretenir une relation avec une
relation avec ton public
est-ce que du coup d'après vous c'est un
peu ce qui différencierait d'autres
approches d'autres médias par exemple
est-ce que ça entretiendra un peu le
côté horizontale de youtube sens commun
que de répondre donc un peu switcher
point je suis d'accord en bref sudoc
entretien le voilà il ya cet aspect là
aussi c'est vrai que on a moins l'aspect
effectivement ou youtube
tu postes à vidéotron c'était en surface
ici tu as du commentaire yade comme ça
se présente à l'ia du retour mais sur
twitter tu as vraiment sûrs en des temps
de discussion comme ça il ya encore plus
d'horizontalité effectivement dans une
réaction sur twitter on va dire créateur
abonnés que sur youtube où là on est sur
des tanks ne va pas de la même façon
effectivement ok je rentre très vite
dans le vif du sujet mais parce que
juste avant terme sinon on est mal barré
quand tu disais je me suis auto perdu
dans ce que je dis oui
la première table ronde sur comment
vivre de ses vidéos sur youtube
vous parliez de l'importance du
financement participatif de tout ce qui
était type et dons du public et que du
coup il y avait un intérêt à entretenir
la relation avec le public et ça passait
les réseaux sociaux permettent
clairement ça d'accord ça permet d'en je
sais pas imaginer prenons un exemple qui
peut être un peu dépassé maintenant mais
la star de cinéma que tu adores t'as vu
tous ses films et ses rames mais jamais
de la vie tu pourras lui parler parce
que déjà la [ __ ] à hollywood et toi tu
habites à tourcoing et et peut-être un
jour tu vas lui envoyer une lettre
parce que tu en as envie tu sais pas si
elle va la lire tu aura de toute façon
jamais de réponse et cetera il ya un
côté distant il ya un côté de cette
personne ne te connais même pas sur les
réseaux sociaux
tu n'es personne et tu peux parler alors
je vais pas dire qu'on est des stars
mais pour certains ont laissé certains
nous considèrent clairement comme ça et
on est des stars mais quand même des
guillemets auquel on peut parler qui
sont entre guillemets accessible
quelqu'un qu'on peut rencontrer dans la
rue quelqu'un d' entre guillemets normal
quelqu'un avec qui on peut échanger on
peut lui envoyer un mail un tweet un
truc sur facebook j'en sais rien on est
des gens qui enfin je pense que pour
certains on a cette image
d'accessibilité qui du coup est d'autant
renforcée par les réseaux sociaux si on
y est c'est sûr que si tu fais juste des
vidéos sur youtube et que tu désactive
les commentaires tu te retrouves un
petit peu comme comme la star
d'hollywood
alors que si au contraire tu interagit
avec les gens tu donnes cette image de
personne accessible et donc qu'on a
peut-être potentiellement envie de
soutenir
après les gt on scrute il est même les
stars allaient ou des choses comme ça
ont quand même enfin sont la plupart
l'un en présence sur les réseaux sociaux
mais c'est pas la même chose dans le
sens où c'est pas la raison lui même
c'est plutôt le côté que même en temps
il ya dans le milieu du tube ya un côté
où il ya eu en effet un espèce de
n'était de proximité extraire quand je
disais ça s'était plutôt well et la
façon politiquement les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui c'est vrai aussi belles les
réseaux sociaux on a fait un truc qui
manque la cible était un mois de mystère
parce qu'à une proximité qui est là et
c'est très plaisant dans le milieu
effectivement agenceur enfin les gens
sur vos sur l'internet
je les dis je les lis et ce avec 14
minutes
ça promet du coup oui tu parlais de ce
lien très direct que vous avez avec
votre communauté
lâchons le deuxième mot est ce que il
n'ya pas ça vous incite pas est-ce que
vous ressentez une pression à vous
exprimer sur les réseaux sociaux à
entretenir un peu une activité comme ça
alors ayant toujours été assez direct et
à comment dire
c'est quoi le mot j'ai jamais été très
propre sur moi on va dire donc je
ressens pas vraiment de filtres moi
quand je m'exprime
maintenant je me connais je pense
carrément pas une généralité tu parler
plutôt de se dire merde aujourd'hui j'ai
pas tweeté il faut absolument que l'on
entretienne salle juste comme ça
ouais
bah non sur youtube j'ai ce truc là
parce qu'effectivement ça prend du temps
de faire une vidéo etc
j'ai conservant ce truc de mer d'une
semaine en corée pas ça y est je crois
une vidéo je pas régulier etc
mais sur twitter c'est vraiment sans
réfléchir les mythes ya des périodes où
je me force à -28 et parce que je me dis
juste pas mal votre combat sinon
naturellement vraiment la détruire c'est
plutôt des trucs inverse
moi je me retiens aussi de 2to commenté
je me retiens de remettre des
commentaires en fait pourquoi pourquoi
ce parce que je me dis qu'ils vont être
beaucoup vu et juste dire merci c'est
cool c'est à paraître dans une timeline
pour ça ça sert pas à grand chose quoi
avec tout ce qu'on fait vous arrêter à
notre merci c'est cool non je déconne
hermes a rejoint un petit peu ce que je
disais thalassa retour direct pour
quelqu'un pour pour quelqu'un
de lambda qui aime bien une chaîne
youtube etc
il poste un commentaire et le vidéaste a
pris le temps de lui répondre à lui pour
de mieux pour le remercier
personnellement oui pour certains ça
compte mais je peux le comprendre
c'est vraiment un jour j'ai pas un
compliment c'est rien ça c'est audio sur
twitter merci c'est génial non mais
après il ya un truc qu'il faut quand
même garder en tête c'est que il restera
toujours une dissymétrie je veux dire
c'est certes un peu plus horizontale
mais en vrai c'est toujours une pente
comme ça monsieur n'a toujours pas
toujours cyprien qui va voir quoi 10 11
millions d'abonnés et le mec qui a 3
follower sur twitter
même s'il peut lui répondre s'il peut
lui dire ce qu'ils pensent s'il peut
faire tout ça il ya quand même une
grosse dissymétrie qui de toute façon ne
disparaîtra pas parce que si elles
disparaissent et que tu as cyprien qui
clashe normal
et pour en revenir à votre usage que
vous faites des réseaux sociaux quel
genre d'information vous diffusez à quoi
vous en servez moi j'ai surtout les
imposer des limites
c'est très intéressant pour l'actualité
en fait dans son sens large voie juste
les infos mais c'est effectivement
twitter c'est tellement l'instant et en
même temps c'est ce qui me fait me dirai
ce que est ce qu'il n'ya pas une
illusion quelque part est ce que
imaginons que je disparaisse de twitter
est ce que ça va avoir des conséquences
j'en sais rien mais sur twitter en tout
cas on a une une masse d'informations
qui est qui et qui était ce qu'il y
avait sur facebook à l'époque même toute
l'info maintenant aller sur twitter et
c'est un bon moyen pour immédiatement se
positionner immédiatement voir si moi
qui ai commenté l'actualité pendant un
certain temps immédiatement voir quelles
sont les réactions des gens à oui tiens
j'ai dit une connerie
donc je peux me re calibrer je peux
très rapidement à avoir un meilleur
discours quoi ça sert pas mal à ça mais
après je pense que ça ne reste pas les
tweets les machins ça s'évapore
il ya un côté très c'est intense et
illusoire fin ça c'est bizarre je sais
pas si tu vois ce que je veux dire je
suis assez d'accord en fait et je
consulte twitter pareil pour chercher de
l'info pour chercher ce qui se passe
c'est pas comme si ce n'était pas
l'heure lors slogan mais vraiment juste
entre guillemets l'abus consultative
quoi tu te suit plus non parce que
twitter est un [ __ ] de champ de
bataille et comme tu peux pas mettre
vraiment de nuances dans un propos en
250 caractère tu te dis je vais juste
donner mon avis et après tu passes 3
heures sur twitter à développer ton avis
parce qu'il ya toujours quelqu'un qui a
pas compris ce que tu voulais dire à ses
romans j'ai autre chose à [ __ ] de mon
temps en fait j'essaie d'avoir où ces
aspects là ce que c'est vrai que moi
toutes les notions où on va aller vers
un vrai message ou une morale autre
comme ça je sais que dans mes vidéos
mais sur twitter c'est toujours très
léger le sco aurait posté je ne regarde
pas parfois j'ai réagi à un truc qui
s'est passé dans les camps mais mon avis
sur un truc a vite fait parfois je vais
quand même faire un thread mais vraiment
c'est un par tous les un ou deux mois
mais sinon c'est je pense hélas pour se
rendre de chez de postes et de vannes
parce que j'aime bien juste trouver
comment dans le monde de caractère comme
ça je vais faire le lot bons mots et la
bonne pop chewing gum s'annoncer plus
cet aspect là ce que j'aime bien écrire
et à quoi une très voilà c'est grisant
sur twitter
effectivement c'est très vrai merci
merci à tous si vous avez des questions
dans le public
n'hésitez pas à intervenir ainsi don au
fur et à mesure vous parlez donc on a
commencé à aborder des limites
enfin les limites des réseaux sociaux et
surtout de twitter pour communiquer pour
s'exprimer
on n'a pas parlé des bulles de filtrage
ce phénomène qui fait qu'en fait ensuite
que les gens qui ont tendance à avoir un
peu qui sont à peu près du même milieu
social qui ont à peu près les mêmes
opinions que nous et du coup ça risque
un peu de radicaliser notre position au
fur et à mesure alors est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ça vous êtes sujet à
ça comment
si comme tu à l'heure je m'inscris en
faux parce que j'essaye justement dû
suivre un maximum de gens avec qui je
suis pas d'accord justement juste parce
que j'essaye d'avoir des avis différents
de voir ce que les autres pensent
qu'elle quelles sont leurs arguments et
c est après pour déterminer si je vais
être d'accord avec eux ou pas après j'ai
toujours le loisir de dire non
finalement je suis pas d'accord avec lui
mais par contre j'estime qu'il est quand
même important d'écouter ce qu'ils ont à
dire
c'est là mais ça reste ça reste quand
même une bulle dans le sens où souvent
on va suivre ou voir des trucs auxquels
on est d'accord
ou alors le total opposé parce que les
gens qui on est d'accord lors 8 et en
échange pas d'accord au final on reste
dans ce débat voilà où il ya où il ya et
il y a juste
j'en ai les avait opposés et je pense
qu'on loupe quand même toute une espèce
de nuances tout un truc direct des
suffrages la veille sur le twitter de ma
femme et je comprends pas dans quel
monde vit qu'est ce que c'est que toutes
ces d'où viennent ces informations
comment ça se fait qu'est ce que c'est
quoi ça parle après on respecte notre
niche dans les trucs avec lesquels tu es
d'accord tel truc avec lesquels tu es en
désaccord mais après tu as aussi
l'énorme nuances de trucs dont on n'a
juste rien à [ __ ] voilà c'est un petit
peu ça la et même ça c'est sur un sujet
mais après on me dit voilà c'est
totalement d'autres sujets c'est
justement notre univers et d'autres
trucs et là on va voir vraiment
difficile à tomber dessus et des fois tu
en effet mais c'est intéressant ça parle
des chiens mais c'est intéressant et
j'aime les chiens c'est pas la question
mais mais cela n'apparaîtra jamais dans
ma timeline alors que pourtant c'est ma
femme on se répond etc
je suis pas comment ils fonctionnent
l'algo twitter d'ailleurs par rapport à
ça je pas trop comment ils comment ils
sélectionnent je me pose des questions
d'ailleurs parce que je regarde souvent
comment réagissent les gens des postes
sur des thématiques
sensibles par exemple récemment il y
accuse des x de chasseurs de fantômes
qui a publié une photo de mon nommé au
mon choix dans la salle d'attenté de son
médecin est sous ce poste il n'y a que
des commentaires contre l'homéopathie
alors est-ce que c'est twitter qui qui
se dit oulala je vais pas lui mettre des
com de gens qui sont pour
sinon il va quitter twitter ou est ce
que il ya vraiment une évolution des
dépenses est ce assez c'est très biaisée
parce que je veux du coup je me suffit
d'une personne contre influentes qui a
recruté le truc pour qu'après toute sa
communauté dans la même avis vient de
commenter
et que je te disais ça c'est ça qui
était intéressant dans le cadre du ces
qui disait rien il mettait la photo et
c'est tout mais est ce que le fait de
enfin est-ce que les gens qui sont
contre 9,7 ne s'exprime pas plus que les
gens qui sont pour ben le simple fait
qu'ils m'ont nommé au mon choix partout
dans toutes les pharmacies me ferait
dire que non et bien que les gens qui
sont pour s'exprimer exprime aussi là
pour le coup les sanctions pourront
effectivement beaucoup j'ai pas si vous
êtes au courant d'ailleurs parce que
nous on est en belgique et a pas ça mais
en france il ya le déremboursement de
l'homéopathie qui est qui est remis en
question le des remboursements par la
sécu sociale et les homéopathes se sont
concilier pour faire une grande action
publicitaire plutôt créé l'eau et donc
il ya des posters partout envoyer des
sms pour participer à la pétition m'ont
nommé au mon choix et c'est ça vous
savez un peu de quoi on parle quand on
avait une question par ici compliquer
les choses qu'on fait on peut le prendre
en guinée si on va le dire en public
correctement la magie n'est pas vraiment
du voyage de notre bâtisse à me remettre
en jeu les anglais
les gens compagnies privées vont le
faire dans la vie peut-être en irl
peut-être mais par contre sur twitter il
ya quand même un sacré anonymat c'est à
dire que nous on a des entre guillemets
des personnalités publiques
j'ai aussi un compte à mon nom soit on
continue aussi à ton nom que le sache
donc on parle en notre nom mais sur
twitter il ya énormément de gens qui
sont cachés derrière un pseudonyme et tu
sauras jamais qui sait et c'est
d'ailleurs justement des gens qui
s'expriment sans aucun filtre parce
qu'ils savent que de toute façon leur
opinion personne va leur reprocher dans
la vie on va peut-être leur reprocher
sur twitter peut-être les vaches et sur
twitter mais ils s'en foutent parce que
personne ne sait qui c'est aussi une
grosse différence
irl et sur internet dans notamment par
rapport à twitter dans son succès est
celle qui est quand même assez neufs
peut-être que la communauté twitter sera
quand même hyper hyper est différente de
la communauté irl et je pense je me
trompe sans doute mais pour reprendre
l'exemple de l'homéopathie peut-être que
ir est justement tu as toutes ces mères
de famille etc qui vont très très peur
appuyer leur décision d'être pour
l'homéopathie etc
draps tandis que peut-être que sur
twitter c'est plus une communauté jeunes
qui justement est influencé par des
youyous beurre je sais pas est ce qu a
aussi twitter ne reflète pas la réalité
ça c'est effectivement et toutes les
couches de la population
voilà on a vu plus les bulles de filtres
plus machin effectivement heureusement
twitter n'est pas la réalité absorbé
plus dans la rue justin lavash tué avec
un fusil et volcans sinon question par
ici surtout que sur twitter c'est facile
de dire quelque chose on pense
réellement sur twitter par exemple que
en réel en réel on n'a plus peur on
applique aux anciens des répercussions
réelles si l'amateur la famille comme
sur les deux témoins de jéhovah ou un
anti vagues ce qui m'avait écrit et le
simple fait de parler de ça dans la
famille un témoin de jéhovah quand il a
commencé à se poser des questions sur le
bien fondé du dogme des témoins de
jéhovah sa famille lui a littéralement
tourné dos je dirais ils ont coupé les
ponts c'est la règle chez eux
voilà et donc forcément dans la vraie
vie il ya des choses qu'on va pas osé
dire parce que on va avoir peur de
répercussions bien concrète le patron et
puis quand je dis dans la vraie vie
c'est aussi sur twitter sous son vrai
nom parce que ça va peut-être avoir des
répercussions au boulot le patron qui va
dire ouais je peux pas de garder parce
que je sais pas vain il peut y avoir des
tapes conséquences si vous dit quelque
chose de manière totalement anonyme
à part peut-être vous faire bloquer
votre compte twitter et puis refaire un
autre compte anonyme bas ça vous
empêchera pas par exemple de cracher
votre haine comme certains gens qu'on ne
citera pas voilà justement ce que tu
disais c'est assez intéressant est ce
que vous êtes tous ici dans ce panel
alors je la trouve plutôt carrées mois
mais après dans cette table
rectangulaire web
les pipes et dick allons-y est
indépendant à votre compte
ou est-ce que vous travaillez pour un
employeur nom n'est pas une réponse je
suis j'avais pas je n'ai pas d'employeur
je n'ai pas de patron dont je travaille
donc tué sa dresseuse de tes propos oui
alors si tu parle que de la chaîne ça
forcément mai
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que même
à côté messieurs robin reste oui non je
pense que tu aurais pas un patron qui
pourraient du jour au lendemain décider
désiré parce qu'on y voit là alors dont
alors est il ya quand même le même cas
dans le sens où j'ai des commandes des
clients et donc c'est chaque cas
effectivement ou parfois j'ai des
profils où je me dis que j'aimerais bien
quand même qu'ils tombent pas sur la
chaîne quoi parce que je me dis ça boit
ça peut influencer un plan c un truc
pour pas que ça se croiser justement je
ne sais pas si ça se croise à se croiser
voilà j'ai le temps je gère pas à cacher
quoi que ça juste de manière générale je
sais par effectivement en activité
professionnelle de youtube et il ya
certains de gens à qui je travaille qui
connaît ceux qui aiment bien en général
parfois même ça va faire en sorte que
que ça ferait un bon contact etc
si jamais on aime bien et il ya des
profils que je vois très bien qui sont
hyper au business etc
je me moque de ce type de personnes donc
forcément j'ai envie qu'ils le voient
pas aidé et si ça arrive ça arrive tout
pillage est pas une grosse crainte non
plus mais voilà j'ai pas le une seule
personne on va dire au patron l'effet
que tout ma vie dépendent autour il ya
un risque que j'ai pas d'accord et
d'ailleurs je vais aussi la question
on parle de réseaux sociaux par exemple
lyndine j'en est vachement j'en ai
vaguement entendu parler quand en avant
aussi mais je suis jamais ne serait-ce
qu'à les voir ce que c'était et y recule
de clash sur linkedin
je me reconnais beaucoup lengliné
comment ça parce que je dire dans le
cadre de ventes à 2,4 de créer un
contenu between de manière d'entreprise
qui communiquent à d'autres entreprises
c'est vraiment le réseau idéal
aujourd'hui il ya tout un tout un monde
que ce soit en grande partie ici
connaissent pas mais android et
influenceurs linkedin ya c'est tout un
truc qui existent comme celle qui assure
sur youtube etc
à part que c'est tout le milieu
corporate et le dire à patrick à dire là
dessus mais voilà effectivement moi ça
correspond pas à mon tour je suis pas
j'ai un peu été dans le cadre de mon
activité pro la dépendance et c'est
parce que c'est idéal pour évidemment
créer un réseau et pouvoir prospects
avant une lente et externe mais je suis
parti parce que c'est clairement en fait
il ya tout un la manière sur twitter et
sur chaque réseau comme c'est le cas sur
instagram etc
il ya un espèce de
il ya des valeurs qui tourne autour du
réseau qui sont là qui sont communes à
ce que tout le monde va poster et ce qui
est rare chez dessus on va dire yens jeu
par un type de personnes typique d'un
type de contenu typique pour chaque
réseau et c'est toute la philosophie et
toutes les valeurs autour de ce concret
comme conduit sur linkedin
c'est quelque chose qu'elle je m'oppose
complètement donc voilà j'ai juste quand
il marche sur le papier mais je ne
jamais trop utilisé en fait je sais que
c'est toi qui fais l'animation mais du
coup je vais un petit peu de voler la
place et te demander et toi dû coûter
réseaux sociaux parce que pour le moment
[Rires]
du coup oui monsieur sam tu as ton
compte aussi qu'elle compte de l idée
des employeurs qui peut je n'ai pas
d'employeur d'accord chômage non on
appelle ça le statut d'artiste en
belgique
bolt a pas de pression particulière
est ce que toi quand tu postent des
messages tu penses à éventuellement des
gens influents qui pourrait regarder
ah bah bien sûr bien sûr et du coup ça
influe sur ta manière de postes devrait
carrément bien sûr je pense auquel je
pense en premier aux collègues
sceptiques j'essaye de j'ai eu je sais
je veux dire c'est pas pour rien que
c'est une communauté
moi je suis pas née du tout sceptiques
gt gt croyant à la base donc c'est en
étant au contact des sceptiques que je
le suis devenu que je suis devenu un
meilleur sceptiques et je continue dans
cette démarche c'est pas parce que
maintenant je fais partie du clan que je
vais arrêter donc effectivement quand je
poste un truc je me dis on l'a peut-être
que christophe michel il va il va être
déçu de moi c'est pas du tout secteur
tout ce que tu veux et alors la pensée
le gourou non c'est pas c'est pas une
question de goût c'est une question de
personne à qui on
on se sent le plus ressemblant de qui on
s'inspire le plus j'ai envie de dire moi
ça a été principalement christophe
michel donc hygiène mentale la chaîne et
c'est une bonne référence de ressentir
je fais souvent cet exercice vous n'êtes
jamais ça vous moi je me dis toujours
tiens qu'est-ce qui va qu'est-ce qui va
re sens que s'il va penser en lisant ça
je m'imagine en train de le démontrer ça
et ça me donne un autre regard sur ce
que je sens que je dis tout simplement
mais je suis pas non plus à me censurer
un jeu ça termine simplement un bon je
vais peut-être tourner ma phrase un
petit peu plus sympathique mans voilà
pourquoi je fais attention à ça dans les
vidéos parce que bon ça s'écrit et je
fais attention à bien présenter les
choses mais sur twitter
n'importe quelle personne qui surtout
tendance va clairement je tiens
absolument qu'un filtre s'agit pas du
tout attention j'aime souvent la vanne
de quand je dis un truc un peu angie de
faire la main de makala sur youtube est
finie c'est vraiment ça cet aspect là me
tracasse peur moi j'ai une approche
différente
je vais encore revenir à mon passé
professionnel
quand j'étais photographe je cherchais
des clients le problème en photo il faut
avant tout les photos plaisent aux
clients la photo est en forme d'art
c'est extrêmement subjective c'est comme
si vous allez à un concert vous pouvez
pas juste dire je vais un concert fort
encore que ce soit quelque chose qui
vous plaisent un minimum vous n'allez
pas emmener un mamie un concert d'acdc 6
qu'elle habite 6 qu'elle écoute
d'habitude c'est du vivaldi donc et
pourtant les deux sons de la musique et
la photo c'est un peu pareil il fallait
donc que je trouve des clients qu'ils
soient un petit peu en accord avec moi
est le meilleur moyen que j'ai trouvé de
le faire c'est d'être extrêmement
contrastés pour le dire comme ça ceux
qui me suivent un peu sur internet
savent que je suis ils ont assez incisif
et c'est d'une certaine manière de
stratégie quand je poste quelque chose
c'est soit quelque chose qui me tient à
coeur soit un trait d'humour parfois
même de l'humour noir foncé un c'est pas
le fait mais c'est soit de l'humour soit
quelque chose qui me tient à coeur est
quelqu'un qui confronté à ça soit ne va
pas comprendre mon humour va le prendre
au premier degré ou un truc comme ça
soit tu vas être en désaccord avec le
truc qui me tient à coeur
eh ben je sais que ça va juste être
quelqu'un avec qui bah je vais peut-être
pas réussir à échanger ou dans le cas de
la photo quelqu'un qu'il ne sera pas un
client avec qui je verrai
ram entendre et donc du coup à ce moment
là j'avais déjà des propos 10 ont
tranché pour dire comme ça et ça faisait
d'une certaine manière le tri et les
gens qui m'aborder quand même je savais
que c'était des gens avec qui j'allais
un minimum en temps ça veut pas dire que
j'ai des propos sectaires et qui
accueille un type de personne qui peut
s'entendre à quoi ça veut juste dire que
les gens qui peut-être n'ont pas
d'humour ou qui n'ont pas certaines de
mes convictions
ben je vais entre guillemets les tenir à
l'écart ça veut pas dire que je suis pas
ouvert au dialogue
bien au contraire d'ailleurs justement
christophe michel et moi avons souvent
des points de vue radicalement opposé
c'est pas pour autant qu'on n'en débat
pas régulièrement mais l'ajustement moi
ce que je vais faire c'est posté un truc
et avant attendre une éventuelle
réaction bas par exemple de christophe
qui me dire là dessus je suis pas
d'accord et c'est ce qu'on va en
débattre en privé
d'ailleurs pour lâcher le morceau on a
entre sceptiques un petit groupe sur qui
s'appelle les illuminati des bilderberg
reprend vincent valade comme ça au
sérieux et on discute souvent de ce
genre de chose tiens t'as vu la dernière
vidéo de machin tu as vu le tweet de
trucs dit toi tu as dis ça je suis pas
en accord avec macha et tout en étant d
accord on est toujours en train de
discuter de manière extrêmement cordial
et
et donc je considère qu'on peut être en
désaccord avec quelqu'un tout en étant
son ami de toute façon si on ne peut
être amis qu'avec des gens qui pensent
exactement comme nous ennuie voilà déjà
en ce fichier et puis on peut tout de
suite monté une secte un quad mais par
contre c'est vrai que parfois je ne vais
pas forcément avoir envie de perdre du
temps avec quelqu'un que je ne connais
pas et qui n'a par exemple aucun humour
je sais que ouais un peu de mal bah en
postant des trucs d'humour l'enjeu c'est
que ce gars live probablement pas venir
me parler en fait donc j'ai pas vraiment
de filtres dans ce que je dis c'est
j'applique le le filtre à l'extérieur en
quelque sorte c'est important pour vous
alors d'avoir des retours sur ce que
vous publiez ce soit sur les réseaux
sociaux sur vos vidéos même en général
oui oui ça m'intéresse surtout souhaité
aller retour vidéo ou les retours sur
des tweets
je considère pas ça comme du contenu
mais ouais les autres vidéos est vrai
que ça je vois parler juste serait que
moi ce qui est intéressant que twitter
c'est des trucs par exemple le site
hésite ci est ce que parler du telle
thématique faire un tel sujet de vidéos
est ce que vraiment c'est intéressant ça
parfois cool de faire un sondage sur
twitter non là ce que ce que ça vous
plairait qu'on parle de ça ou plutôt de
sa de trancher ou de vrais sujets ou
même pour t&d au sujet de me dire tiens
moi je pense que peut-être la plupart
des gens à penser comme ça parce que
c'est vraiment vrai ben t'as une
communauté à disposition pour faire un
sondage d'hier est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça et du coup tu peux
l'amener à de ses rares montées ton
sujet pareil à ce truc là exprès
expérimental horizontalité asaew
effectivement voilà faire du test de
contenus faire
la tension ce qu'il a fait dans une
vidéo le tester sur twitter pour voir si
c'est le genre de sujet qui va marcher
en version vidéo des trucs comme ça
c'est utile est il aussi me montrer un
nouveau logo des trucs comme ça ça c'est
le genre de chose que moi je fais pas
sur twitter du coup je n'utilise pas
mais dans l'onglet communauté de youtube
par exemple
ah oui c'est vrai ils oublient suis là
et ça marche bien tu peux avoir des
retours je suis parfois impressionnés du
nombre de gens qui laissent des
commentaires je n'arrive pas à tout lire
c'est il y en a trop il ya vraiment un
gros fan je sais pas pour les autres
mais sur chine il ya un énorme retour
dans l'onglet communauté clairement pas
autant que les vidéos mais
impressionnant jusque twitter quand même
je pense ouais enfin que je mène vrai je
pense
et pour en revenir donc ces histoires de
propos je sais pas où j'allais avec
cette phrase je vais là continuez comme
ça est-ce que vous assumez toujours les
propos que vous avez sur les réseaux
sociaux
qu'est ce que ça vous êtes arrivé déjà 2
qu'est-ce que tu appelleras fumée
d'hésiter bas genre où justement on
vient de voir apprendre en dis donc t'as
dis ça c'est vraiment sûr tous à assumer
ça voudrait dire laisser le tweet en
place restait sur ta position tu vois
c'est un peu plus ce obstiné non
d'accord ce qu'on peut dire assumer du
genre ok j'ai dit une connerie je la
corrigerai tiens oui d'accord
toi tu es plus dans cette posture là moi
je suis dans la correction permanente
ok c'est beau mais je pense qu'il faut
il faut savoir reconnaître ses torts
mais quand on dit quelque chose et quand
on le pense même si c'est pas forcément
quelque chose de populaire
je pense qu'il faut aussi de temps en
temps avoir les couilles de dire non
parce que je pense je ne suis pas
d'accord avec vous et baboo tout comme
vous avez le droit de ne pas être
d'accord avec moi
mais je pense que si tu veux toujours te
plier à l'avis des autres et ne jamais
froisser personne sur les réseaux
sociaux il faut les quitter tout de
suite c'est clair de toute façon tu va
déplaire à des gens donc il faut quelque
part l'assumer quoi ça vous est arrivé
quand même de d'hésiter ou de renoncer à
publier quelque chose parce que vous
vous êtes dit ça pourrait blesser une
partie de mon audience annonça non pas
par rapport le nom annonce qu'il va pas
trop de films et ça arrive à pas après
ou ses comptes ce que je veux la tension
était pas du tout de dire ça et
peut-être parce que j'ai mal formulé le
truc joie dans le joie dans les réponses
que ça va pas être du tout été perçu
comme c'était voulu puis un très bon
parfois c'est pire de venir justifier
ans ou d'expliquer alors tu vas laisser
traîner comme ça est ce pas une
catastrophe mais du coup soit ça
t'embête etc et et surtout oui voilà il
ya toute une culture de ne pas supprimer
7 8 aussi qui est quelque chose de
considérée comme assez grave
moi j'ai moi je souris mais si jamais
genre je les poster j'ai vu qu'ils
jouent à qui une faute et je l'enlève
mais une fois qu'il est parti qu'il a pu
au moins quelques minutes qui est des
likes considère qu'il peut plus être
supprimables attention si tu le fais en
général takayuki var posté une capture
d'écran à il a supprimé son tweet c'est
un truc que je trouve impressionnant
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya des gens peu
importe il faut que ça à [ __ ] comme
toute la journée ils font des screen
leur timeline au cas où
en fait c'est leur méga qu'il y en a un
qui est supprimée fin de journée quand
tu dis que c'est mal vu de supprimer un
tweet alors qu'il y en a qui commandent
des tweets en marquant supprime
quid expliqué ben ouais
oui mais en fait si je pense que c'est
un côté un petit peu schizophrène de
dire toi t'a dit de la merde tu
supprimes et une fois qu'il a supprimée
at avait eu l'assument by la supprimer
mais ça veut dire ça n'a aucun sens
ouais quelle est la menace a corrigé
alors d'après pardon j'étais
complètement interrompue non je vais
même effectivement c'est comme ça que ça
se passe avec le temps que l'on supprime
qu'une fois que tu fais par contre ça va
pas non il n'y a pas de pas de bonne
solution mais oui c'était vraiment une
connerie l'idéal c'est de refaire de
repose t on si vraiment tu dois vraiment
justifié ces de reposter en dessous une
réponse propres tweets et de nuancer le
truc par exemple où tu te corriger comme
ça mais du coup les gens peuvent
continuer à lire uniquement le premier
tweet tu t'es trompé et le relayer et ça
peut diffuser une fin de news
oui mais ça c'est un projet à l'autre
venir avec un sur huit
voilà mais il sera toujours collé en
dessous de zéro on peut voir que le
premier c'est quand même pour moi un des
gros problèmes de twitter c'est que
c'est un endroit pour poster ce que ta
bouffe et à midi mais pour développer
des opinions complexe c'est vraiment pas
le bon endroit à cause justement de ce
format de ce système
ta 250 caractère ensuite il faut nuancer
si tu peux si tu en as pas déjà 12 qui
ont surinterpréter ton propos ta réponse
août à nuance va forcément être moins vu
je veux dire le mec qui fait un trade tu
vois le premier puis le reste souvent tu
dire ou pas etc
c'est pour moi c'est vraiment pas c'est
un média pour la spontanéité pour
l'immédiateté n'est clairement pas pour
le débat où les idées complexes je pense
que c'est accueillie comme telle en plus
je pense que c'est pas pris aussi au
sérieux que les vidéos
oui je pense qu'il ya une plus grande
tolérance justement au foutoir sur
twitter
donc chaque tweet n'est pas vu comme un
communiqué par exemple alors que je
pensais officiel que c'est en fait ce
sauf ça dépend la forme que tu lui mets
quoi sauf si c'est élise lucet d'envoyé
spécial qui balance un truc bon elle son
métier c'est d'informer
et de faire des choses devraient donc
dépendre la position donc on est souvent
dit voilà il ya la prétention qui
accompagne évidemment la prétention des
journalistes c'est de donner la vérité
donc enfin en tout cas de certains
journalistes c'est du personnage si les
attelages de que ce soit sur youtube ou
sur twitter est un troll un peu et que
sur twitter du coup il reste que le
troll tout l'étude peuvent être pris à
la légère
youtube heures qui sont rôle celui sur
youtube qui le sont sur twitter
inversement qu'ils ne sont pas foutu
mais le son c'est ça oui c'est un peu
mon astuce c'est un peu ce que je sorte
mon astuce de créer de la confusion vous
emmène connais tu peux vite fait normal
tu peux dire que tabou fait un truc à
midi et derrière tu peux dire
aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de supprimer ma
chaîne youtube parce que machin est là
du coup ça va avoir une valeur
officielle alors que le tweet d'avant
c'était c'est aussi le contenu du tweet
qui va faire son sérieux finalement la
wii voilà il ya la prétention de la
personne qui l'accompagnent cancan l
inverse quand tu as par exemple je crois
que celle est qui
qui posait la question qui se pose la
question de l'impact du like donc juste
ça le fait de mettre un petit coeur
qu'est-ce que je communique à mon public
du coup moi je sais que les réfléchit à
des trucs comme ça donc en laye fait un
tweet je veuille attention les a fait un
tweet toi c'est pas c'est pas le même
truc quoi c'est juste en fait pourquoi
sur twitter pour ma voix je fais du sur
twitter j'ai juste de tout vidéo qui ont
parfois si tu rates un rien oui mais ces
scènes ne comprends pas c'est pourquoi
vous visiez pourquoi vous bien formés si
je me sens que celle que des trolls que
des informations dressage événementielle
qui sourit très vite un sit in et on
ressent que je vois pas pourquoi être
surprise si j'ai en tant que s'est il
passé du temps pour un peu quand même
alors de recueillir des avis pertinents
mais disons qu'il faut oui parce que il
ya un avis général où tout le monde et
ouais c'est le bordel et c'est ce qui a
fait l'avis général et autour de la
table le saumon le dit comme ça mais
c'est peut-être un avis à populaire ou
j'sais pas moi je suis hyper à l'aise
fâcheuse twitter il forum n'est pas du
tout de problème avec twitter bon en
fait je trouve ça j'ai pas cette vision
tout le monde dit genre là c'était juste
une énorme faute wars est horrible c'est
voilà deux mois ça me va encore je
trouve que c'est plutôt sympathique
twitter en fait même on l'a dit tout à
l'heure
ouais c'est ça on l'a dit c'est la seule
à la relation plus passer la gérer au
quotidien avec la partie très engagée de
la communauté le côté expérimental la
croyance à tout ça
c'est un outil complémentaire en fait
c'est une source d'information
incroyable à côté des médias mainstream
et et ça va vite ça va quel intérêt de
voir un truc qui se périment tout de
suite oui parce que là aussi on répond
on répond en tant que tu veux mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya la question à se poser du
groupe en quoi c'est utile en temps par
contre que du coup n'importe qui et ça
je le vois un peu moins ce qui serait
que moi je suis sur twitter que depuis
la chaîne et j'ai toujours été que dans
ce cadre là donc je sais pas quelle
utilité j'aurais juste en tant que
peut-être poursuivre justement bal des
comptes twitter de vider à ce que j'aime
bien quoi peut-être
si le créatif créatif ve fait leur vidéo
sur un sujet que je ne comprends pas des
masses twitter lui permettrait
potentiellement de contacter quelqu'un
qui s'y connaît bien et plus facilement
des témoignages aussi des trucs comme ça
témoignage et puis aussi tout ce qui est
la source d'information
j'insiste un peu parce que je suis
journaliste à côté et twitter c'est
vraiment ça n'est parfait et c'est là
dessus qu'on trouve des mines
d'informations mais folle pour les actus
scientifique fin c'est vraiment génial
les trucs qu'on trouve pas dans l'est
dans les communiqués de presse dans les
tout ça parce que tu peux aller
directement t'abonner à des
scientifiques qui te sortent les best-of
de ski ce qu'ils voient pas c'est parce
que là on parle beaucoup de en quoi ces
pertinentes 8 heures et jusqu'à demain
on a été je sais pas ce que c'est prévu
mais le sujet tourne autour de twitter
mais pour l'état pour déterminer sa
valeur il faut aussi comparer à ckoi du
coup les autres réseaux et la plupart
des trucs qu'on dit que son possible ici
pour moi c'est parce qu'ils sont pas
possibles autre part qu on est sur des
mentalités départ des fonctions
notamment différents si on regarde
vraiment les trucs principaux pour moi
on va considérer que
instagram il ya facebook mais qui est
vraiment en train de s'éteindre surtout
pour sa génération et les gens ils sont
parce qu'on a toujours été expert même
ça n'a plus du tout de valeur aux yeux
des gens à s'abonner sur une totale
autre chose on sait jusqu en fait y'a
pas d'équivalent de ce que 7 8 heures au
niveau de caumont l'utilisent quoi ça je
regarde quand même que l'intitulé sait
s'exprimer même si on n'a rien à dire et
on n'a parlé que de twitter
coïncidence croit pas et on s'est
beaucoup exprimé est ce que ça veut dire
quoi la d'expliciter donc petit fan fact
parce que quand même c'est ta blonde
était préparée selon les chiffres de
2010 8,2 ou de suite et de lagence we
are sochaux 1 belge moyen passe 1h31 par
jour sur les réseaux sociaux et donc tu
parlais des réseaux en question 65% sont
sur facebook 36% sur instagram à 11% sur
twitter alors qu'on en parle tout le
temps mais il ya une grosse différence
par contre au niveau dire qu'il ya eu au
début d'année 2010 etc
c'était très ancrée en france d'être sur
twitter lacombe est logique vraiment pas
du tout il va payer à l'autre ça change
pas ça m'étonne pas du tout que le
chiffre soit comme ça sur twitter c'est
vraiment je sais pas j'ai pas acquis
dans la salle mais je pense que sur
twitter a eu beaucoup moins de succès en
belgique que ç'a eu en france ont par
contre moi j'ai une question alors on a
du coup on n'a pas parlé d'instagram je
viens de commencer instagram oui j'étais
trois photos non si je suis sur un style
mais effectivement poussé beaucoup moins
naturel de créer du contenu dessus
toujours 60 et il est mort aussi vite
qu'il est né et donc du coup je me
demande sincèrement instagram est ce que
c'est quelque chose à part pour les
wannabe photographes et les m'as-tu-vu
est ce que c'est vraiment un réseau
social passe
perso j'ai jamais trouvé aucun intérêt
je crois que tout sous jeux si ces
secteurs
je parle par exemple pas qui est
photographe ou quelqu'un qui fait de
l'art plastique ou même autre chose
je pense qu instagram a une utilité bien
différente par exemple de facebook
d'accord vraiment pour du contenu
justement visuel quelques instants g il
ya un certain standing du beau du bon
contenu croyances et moi poubelle tu
peux choisir de façon peu mieux pourquoi
mais je veux dire t'as pas la même
les gens voient mois de l être sur
facebook vous pourrez les voir se situe
sita film commence mais surtout c'est un
canal peut suffire lui-même giron là on
parle de twitter comme une annexe à
youtube et c'est là où il ya des
influenceurs instagram qui se suffisent
instagram est l'équivalent de détruite
ça va être les stories est l'équivalent
de cornaux posté une vidéo c'est
vraiment le post instagram qui devient
vraiment un événement souvent ils
remettent limette une story pour dire
j'ai fait un post à cette agréable j'ai
fait ma j'ai posté ma photo etc
c'est vraiment un contenu en tant que
tel et ça tourne autour de ça donc ça
réseau à part entière après les
vidéastes en général qui tease instagram
beaucoup ça va plutôt du côté des
youtuber meanstream parce qu'il touche
une cible jeune qui est sur instagram et
vont être à faire des story toute la
journée la même manière que nous 28 et
les heures des choses comme ça mais
c'est un autre public j'ai vraiment rien
compris à comment ça marche moi je
disais il utilise beaucoup moins
naturellement parce qu'il ya il faut
amener du visuel etc ça on est vieux on
assister mon compte instagram trois fois
et les remords la paix mais pareil à
chaque fois que j'essaye je me dis mais
dont j'y comprends rien je dois être
vieux qui parmi vous et sur instagram
petit sondage way a plus que sur twitter
largement alors qui n'est pas un wannabe
photographe et qui n'est pas un
m'as-tu-vu baisser les bras
à vous voir pour la plupart des gens ils
votent sur instagram mais peut-être vous
postez même aucune photo c'est juste
pour suivre des compte instagram
c'est ça bakri qui crée vraiment du
contenu sur instagram une percée g vous
êtes influence raconte une influence ou
instagram
alors comme situer au niveau forcément
que tullaye pourquoi sur facebook en
général plus ou moins sont à féliciter
cantonné à des weight a enfermé
d'antenne dans tes amis ta g c'est
parfois un peu plus basse oui ça ça
permet de s'étendre plus c'est beaucoup
moins fermée que facebook
là où twitter ça encore plus exagérer
stockage et d'accor s'est arrêté sur
chaque réseaux sociaux de toute façon le
contenu tu vas voir un marché en
fonction des centres d'intérêt et dans
lequel tu mets plus engagement c'est ce
qu'on attend c'est dire que de toute
façon si les réseaux sociaux sont
différents et ont un système de
fonctionnement différent c'est justement
tout l'intérêt c'est de plaire à chacun
en fonction de ce qu'ils cherchent sur
un sujet auquel faisait pareil puisse
enfin par rapport à voir avec celle de
demain par exemple ça s'arrêtait pour
ici de lacq raison est ce que votre
tenue antérieures toutes vos vidéos
pourrait pas porter je suis pas dire
malheur mais vous pourrez vous empêcher
de potentiellement tournant le travail
quoi est-ce que ça ça ne vous fais pas
tu veux dire genre notre patron serait
promet au pathé
mais par exemple contre conques les
radios voilà donc les rajouts derrière
daniau les radios du thorax
j'ai fait un bon coup férir et son
paradis obligé contre de ce sujet est
bon bah vous avez perdu
vous n'êtes plus sur youtube pour x
raisons pour chercher un travail
et partout vous postulez par rapport à
2008 une vidéo vous avez posté on vous
dit non
est ce que ça vous fait pas peur non non
mais parce que tu as souvent jamais
engagé chez opening je vous ai tout à
l'heure tu vois c'est que ce patron là
de toute façon je n'aurais pas envie de
bosser pour lui oui c'est ça un peu
inéluctable et c'est là voilà on est on
je pense que nous ici on est tous assez
honnête envers nos communautés ont on
triche pas sur qui on est quoi oui et
puis en vrai on est aussi sans fausse
modestie quoi on est plutôt apprécié je
veux dire si tu regardes le ratio booth
bleus poussent rouge
on n'est pas en a pas on a pas vraiment
de contenus polémique alors oui
polémique pour certains complotistes
peut-être mais disons que globalement on
est plutôt appréciée donc je dirais que
probablement plus un avantage
par exemple pour une bonne exemple bas
moins il ya le côté ou avant j'ai
travaillé en agence de pub et maintenant
je critique la plume dans des vidéos et
on pourrait croire que du coup bah c'est
mort je peux pas revenir en arrière et
bosser en agence et que je obligé de
fonctionner quand même tout seul et
d'avoir des mes propres clients
or en fait depuis la chaîne jamais
autant de propositions d'emploi en
agence dotée en fait ces genres les gens
voient que je critique et je me moque de
certains trucs non général ça fait
marrer les gens du milieu et c'est comme
un espèce de gros cv je cherche tout le
temps on est trop près sûr c'est que je
pars bosser dans ce milieu là mais en
tout cas ça m'a pas du tout fermer de
portes au contraire après west tu parles
d'un seul sujet si vraiment un jour tu a
défoncé une entreprise précise oui c'est
sûr que tu vas voir post il est allé
voilà genre moi je fais du losc
communiste est sûr qu il va pas
m'engager un jour mais j'ai pas envie
d'aller bosser là quoi par contre moi je
crois que je serai du genre si j'ai
défoncé une entreprise à prêt à poster
céder sur cv chez eux pour le plaisir
vraiment un emmerdeur oui le troll quoi
suffisamment meilleur mais oui c'est ça
rejoint un peu ce qu'on disait dans la
première table enfin ce que vous disiez
ce que je sais plus qui dans la première
table ronde sur vivre de ses vidéos sur
youtube en fait avoir une chaîne youtube
c'est avant tout une super vitrine
tu as tout raté c'est plus de portes que
ça n'en ferme ouais assez donc toi c'est
pas beaucoup entendu parler de toi
félicitations si c'est vrai en plus oui
c'était toi sur l'autoroute
qu'est-ce qu'on peut l'applaudir
[Rires]
oui donc ça ouvre plus de portes que ça
n'en ferme d'avoir une chaîne youtube
parce que les gens pensent enfin c'est
l'esprit d'initiative s'est rassemblée
unie paix tu peux gagner 10 euros en en
perdant 1 tu vas dire oui j'en ai j'en
ai gagné 9
si je te dis tu peux ouvrir neuf portes
en fermant une et excusez moi je me
permet quand même de méfiance parce que
ça dépend très très forts de votre
contenu de youtube heures parce que je
prends deux amis français de youtube
euse française communes qui se sont fait
démonter comme jamais par internet
marion seclin qui à cause d'une vidéo
sur l'harcèlement du jeu parle même pas
du contenu de la vidéo je parie qu'elle
sape et art ceci d'harceler elle a même
fait un top tellement tellement elle
s'en est pris plein la gueule ça c'est
un exemple que je suppose beaucoup de
personnes connaissent et je pense
notamment sa bague - plus de niches non
seulement je te parle sa vidéo sur une
escorte elle ça fait démonter a perdu
énormément d'une partie de ce jury par
rapport à ça donc je pense quand même
que ça dépendrait pas dans les chaînes
sceptiques et un peu une espèce de
continuité que si vous faites des
erreurs
oui on n'est pas représentatif de tous
les youtube
et puis en fait cela aussi forcément les
sujets que tu évoques je pense que le
rap le raptor dissidents aura peut-être
plus de mal à savage du look nous tu
vois ça va dépendre des sujets que que
tu abordes dans les thèmes sceptique on
essaye de en général on se mouille pas
trop voilà ne pas avoir d'opinion de
chercher les faits donc on peut pas
vraiment nouveau
enfin il ya toujours des gens qui nous
le reprocheront mais au-delà de ça on
n'est pas vraiment politisé ça c'est un
truc qui est extrêmement clivant et pour
lequel oui là on peu pareil je pense que
usuels si demain il veut chercher du
hulu est le patron et de droite je suis
pas sûr qu'il va le prendre mais comme
nous on fait des trucs pas trop clivant
je pense que pour nous c'est pas un
problème par contre pour d'autres c'est
sur mais bon à un moment je pense qu'ils
assument aussi leurs propos et là j'ai
envie je c'est dommage qu'il n'ait pas
qu'ils soient présents parce qu'ils
auraient peut-être quelque chose
d'intéressant à santos où 110 sans doute
rejoint la question de la responsabilité
de nos propos sur les réseaux sociaux et
ailleurs mais c'est pour ça que j'ai
toujours personnellement considéré qu'il
fallait justement assumer ce qu'on dit
en public
je me souviens quand fut un temps disait
encore que facebook c'était le mal parce
que ça dévoile la vie privée de tout le
monde
mais si tu mets pas des photos de toi
bourré en slip personnes les verra je
veux dire c'est au jeu c'est aux gens
dans la suite et leur photo de mme
andrée ensuite parce que finalement les
réseaux sociaux c'est comme brailler
dans la rue les gens peuvent vous
entendrez donc vous devez prendre la
responsabilité de ce que vous dites et à
partir du moment où on assume tout ce
qu'on dit sur les réseaux sociaux
bah il n'y a pas vraiment de problème
finalement si c'est des propos qu'on
aurait assumé de toute manière dans la
limite de la légalité quoi bon sens et
d'utilité publique aussi qui est sa fin
et youtube heures qui pour des raisons
qu'on accepte pas dérange parce que les
conséquences de tout ça que c'est
horrible pour marion seclin qu'elle se
soit fait clasher autant pour sa vie
personnelle c'est quelque chose d'assez
dramatique mais dans l'autre côté
globalement ça eu une certaine utilité
publique aussi tout ça je pense que ça
peut faire évoluer les mentalités mais
par contre quand tu disais que ça ferme
des portes marion s'est plaint de ces
fermer des portes ce soir
mais d'abord sur un plan professionnel
je n'en sais rien personnellement mes
onze qu'au niveau de sa chaise au niveau
de son contenu et je pense que ça a
énormément marqué ans parce que dans le
justement le thème tokyo et paris du
cyber harcèlement même pour sa vie
personnelle je prends ça a été
à extrêmement dur c'est juste pour la
photo
ces feuillus peux pas m'en lasse pas
j'écoutais sécurité c'est juste pour la
photo
baba par exemple mais pour le pour les
coûts des abonnés perdus
je crois que ça nous est arrivé à tous
d'avoir un pic de désabonnement je me
souviens j'avais j'avais fait une vidéo
sur jean pierre petit en défense en
scylla
alors je me suis un peu fait défoncer
dans les commentaires du leader gilles
si vous n'êtes pas contents au pire
cassez-vous là une cinquantaine qui sont
barrées j'en ai eu trois fois plus
qu'ils sont arrivés j'ai tu peux
préciser qui est jean pierre petit c'est
un sentiment un astrophysicien qui a
essayé de développer une va appeler ça
une théorie du tout je serai en fait ça
tient avec du scotch ans c'est bien
voilà aimé lui présente ça comme comme
grande vérité et puis là aussi nous une
manière de ne pas trop ouvert au
dialogue et et surtout certains croient
ça comme une grande vérité alors que
n'ont pour le moment c'est carrément pas
du tout démontrer mêmes tendrait plutôt
à montrer que c'est faux mais il ya un
côté sectaire dans les gens qui le
suivent je dis pas qu'il est un gourou
de secte mais les syndromes de galilée
well et les gens qui laissent des
commentaires là dessus sont le croient
aveuglément alors que la plupart n'ont
rien compris à ce qu'il a dit l idée
lille découvre l'astrophysique via jean
pierre petit et donc ils se disent
forcément qu'il a raison voilà et du
coup l'ayant critiqué bas lui il m'a
envoyé toute sa communauté alors ça a
essayé de cacher un peu mais bon ils
savaient pas qu'ils avaient en face qui
t'a pas surnommé vlog non ça c'était ça
c'était jacques grimaud zagré mot pardon
et et là aussi il a aussi coaché code
quand je suis tombé sur la gueule à
jacques grimaud alors ça c'était très
drôle parce que j'ai fait un blog donc
la vidéo s'appelait vlog tirer grimaud
entend merde parce qu'il a essayé de
censure écoles de youtube heure et demie
jacques grimaud est un complotiste on va
dire tout simplement aidant complotistes
il ya con parce que juste derrière il a
fait un billet sur facebook où il disait
un youtube heures qui se cache derrière
le pseudonyme de vlog donc du coup on en
a pas mal on en a pas mal rigolé mais
voilà et oui et forcément encore quand
on dit des choses clivante comme ça il y
à temps en temps quelques abonnés qui
d'écart et nathan je crois que tu as eu
le cas aussi récemment on en avait
discuté l'a fait une vidéo sur c'était
quoi exactement résident inattendu
chasse et pompes intelligence entre les
hommes et les femmes
voilà vous ouais il avait un petit but à
cliquer aussi est il là il a eu peur
parce qu'au moment de la diffusion de la
vidéo il a perdu quelques abonnés
j'éteins t'inquiète pas t'inquiète pas
c'est ouais voilà c'est ça c'est mais
justement c'est là où je voulais en
venir c'est sûr que dans leur cas c'est
seas égalité mais dans son cas elle
aussi en fait les abonnés que tu perds à
ces moments là c'est les abonnés qui
sont tellement pas d'accord avec toi
qu'ils ont décidé de se désabonnent des
abonnés pour eux c'est une sanction est
aussi le truc pas malgré tout ce qu'a
vécu était horrible comme ça il y à
toutes les conséquences après dont a
parlé sévère que celle ramenée à forte
dose a amené à sensibiliser
ça lui a amené toute une nouvelle
communauté parce qu'elle avait eu à
combattre sa communauté l'a rejoint
attendez là vous vous dites pas que le
fait qu'elle est une bonne chose
finalement relâchés après après qu'elle
ait vécu tous après qu'elle a vécu tout
ce truc tout ce truc horrible et ben du
coup voilà il ya eu ces conséquences là
il ya eu ces conséquences qu'elle a
salué année en parler cela venait à
rejoindre un combat et c'est quoi tu
vois ce que je veux dire c'est que la
communauté que tu as après un truc comme
ça
et probablement plus derrière toi que
celle que tu avais avant qu'ils étaient
plus mitigés et que du coup tu as un des
avec ce clash et ménez
elle a rendu son message plus folles
vraiment oui mais pour ces questions de
pour revenir à ces questions de
responsabilité
est ce que vous pensez à ça parce que
justement le raptor il a fait une vidéo
sur marion c'est là et c'est toute sa
communauté qui est allé qu'il harcelait
ce que ça vous quand vous vous exprimer
sur les eaux sociaux vous pensez à ce
genre de huy de réaction oui très
clairement oui
ce que vous mettez en garde de la peur
envoyé sa communauté avec un toit chez
combi par exemple ben voilà c'est ça que
je vais pas le faire avec un autre
créateur et c'est moi je trouve que ça
va tant que ça va être une institution
une marque unique soit perçu une seule
personne a ciblé parce que du coup voilà
c'est pas très grave que tout le monde
commence à clasher combiné ou fanta ou
des choses comme ça parce qu'il n'y a
pas une personne qui va être qui va être
touchée qui va être vraiment mal
personnellement et donc je trouve que ça
va ça c'est un gros danger sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est il ya un espèce
d'effet de meute
si un influenceur et là c'est le cas de
le dire dit quelque chose les gens qui
globalement sont d'accord avec lui ou le
suive ou quoi et plus ou moins
aveuglément
certains vont juste puisse se sentir
pisser et se dire qu'ils ont de bonnes
excuses d'aller cracher toute leur haine
à quelqu'un quelqu'un qui peut être
qu'il ne connaissait pas juste avant
qu'il ne leur a rien fait mais parce
qu'ils ont passé une mauvaise journée
parce que le patron a été un peu con etc
il faut qu'il s'en prenne à quelqu'un et
on a cet effet de meute où tout un tas
de gens vont aller crier leur haine à
quelqu'un d'autre parce qu un
influenceur on a éventuellement dit du
mal et ça c'est vrai que c'est un truc
dont je me méfie un petit peu quand je
dis du mal de quelqu'un
j'essaie grimaud tu l'a pas ratée je
crois et mais qui à côté aussi grimaud
lui je me suis pas méfiée grimaud je
voulais un moment foutent un peu le
bordel mais justement c'était décidé
mais il faut faire très attention parce
que ça peut vite déraper même si vous
dit quelque chose de vaguement incisif
ou quoi ça peut vite dégénérer en drame
puis telle affluence qu'on l'a aussi
qu'ils vont après les gens vont tout une
partie vont suivre aussi aveuglément et
avoir un avis extrêmes sur le truc qui
fait rage
j'ai re tweeté un truc j'ai pu hier ou
quoi sûr qu'on venait justement survenu
et quelqu'un répondu en dessous
ouais j'ai un ami qui est a décidé de
bosser là il me dégoûter tout achat de
l'ircam toi cependant plus des
meurtriers les gens prennent la vie
extrême parce que moi je les critiques
et le truc que vraiment c'est le mal
absolu alors que voilà c'est un petit
peu
dans un sens j'ai compris la vidéo
c'était positif je veux dire elle était
contre ce qu'elle passe à c contre le 6e
balle mémoire donc match je précise que
je ne la suis pas personnellement je ne
suis pas la meilleure personne pour en
parler mais donc c'était une vidéo sur
l'art seconde contre le harcèlement
ce qu'elle a subi en fait ça lui a
permis d'avoir mal heureusement ou
malheureusement ce qu'elle a subi
c'est-à-dire le sida salon ça lui a
permis de se faire connaître par le plus
de vous voir plus de personnes possible
de venir maintenant on en parle même
s'il n'est pas présente au mans parle
ici par exemple on en parle
je sens un peu partout force à la main
message de base avec ce qui s'est passé
malheureusement un très bel et de son
message à son combat est devenu 100 fois
plus fort téléfilm vidéo qui était cette
vidéo s'est reportée sur plusieurs
communautés sur youtube tout le monde a
entendu parler même c'est que comment
elle a été accueillie parce que certes
elle a été beaucoup plus vu qu'elle ne
l'aurait été autrement je sais pas mais
le raptor dissident lui a quand même
envoyé un bon paquet de mecs qui étaient
juste là pour la menacer et tout ça donc
je pense que la communauté sac avec sa
communauté n'a pas été suffisant pour la
défendre par rapport à celle du raptor
qu'il a des français
3 aussi et la vie parce qu'elle a fait
une vidéo en réponse du cou à cette idée
là forcément ça arrive l'erreur est
humaine la première vidéo était
peut-être un peu maladroite le propos le
fond du propos avaient sans doute un
insensé que c'était mais la manière dont
s'était amené pouvait être mal
interprétés parce que la vidéo a été un
peu maladroite et je pense que c'est ça
qui a justement généré cette espèce
c'est bon ça comme par exemple pour mon
travail de tous à tous ceux squeeze sur
l'année de des pyramides
là on l'a pas ratée par vincent ce fusil
l avantage c qui s'est repris dans l'air
ouais mais là aussi quand on a quand on
a décidé d'en parler on a quand même
manger nombreux petits contes ça a été
fait avec beaucoup de travail et le ton
oui voilà on a réfléchi à comment on
allait faire ça parce qu'on ne voulait
pas envoyer nos communautés genre à
légitimer fils et tu vois ce pas ça il
fallait éviter ça le raptor dissidents
il a un petit peu dans cette optique là
ouais ouais si peu en braveheart
ouais mais en fait le rapteur dissidents
il l'envoie pas directement sa
communauté non plus mais comme il a des
propos très contrastées les gens ont
plus facilement tendance est vrai il est
très contrastée ce garçon et il fait des
montages très contrastées il devrait
peut-être nouveau genre d'attention non
mais c'est des vidéos qu'il faut
regarder en 0,75 tu sais pour bien et
bien sûr ces belles paroles je propose
de conclure la table ronde
si chacun un mot
aspirateur mère j'allais faire elle-même
a gelé plus âgé parce que seulement deux
modes fin je sais pas je très bonne
question pour la youtube monnaie ce à
quoi la youtube je me suis pas cet agité
mais je me sens toujours pas maintenant
donc c'est juste que c'est juste que je
le fais parce que j'aime bien
oui après j'ai envie de te poser une
autre question c'est pourquoi pas c'est
très pointu c'est un concours de
circonstances se sait dans la vie on
choisit très peu les choses qu'on fait
c'est pourquoi est ce que tu te
retrouves à tel boulot bas parce que ça
s'est présentée et c'était ça ça me
plaisait bien c'était le voit la cdc les
occasions qui passe moi j'ai pas j'ai
pas décidé un matin de devenir youtuber
tu vois c'est voilà moi c'est juste
parce que là c'est je regardais beaucoup
youtube et puis je me suis dit tiens je
ferai une chaîne c'est sympa mais
c'était un hobby comme allez je vais pas
faire faire du pédalo le week end
j'ai pas mis dedans d'ambition dessus de
voilà puis tout d'un coup après il se
passe tout ça puis après on se retrouve
à un moment je fais au fur et à mesure
j'ai eu un petit peu cette démarche pour
astronomiques mais j'avais déjà une
chaîne youtube avant les jeux ayant déjà
l'expérience d'une chaîne youtube je me
suis dit je vais construire un autre
projet mais du coup j'ai réellement
construire un projet sachant toute
l'expérience de youtube que j'avais
avant mais la première fois que tu
arrivé sur youtube c'est j'ai eu une
occasion un mec qui m'a demandé de faire
une vidéo
j'ai fait la vidéo et oui c'est comme ça
seul moi c'est un jeu suivez gus dx un
chasseur de fantômes j'ai vu j'ai vu une
vidéo où il y avait ce que je
considérais être une preuve à l'époque
de d'un phénomène de télékinésie
j'ai étudié la vidéo j'ai découvert un
artefact de trucages et je me suis dit à
ce moment là voilà tu vois j'ai été
l'opportunité est arrivé je veux quand
je veux quand je veux quand j'ai étudié
la vidéo je t'ai pas en train de me dire
si je trouve quelque chose je ferai une
vidéo est alors j'aurai des millions de
vues gg wave sur un sheep storm plus tôt
mais c'est effectivement un jour de buzz
et voilà l'occasion se présente j'ai
fait une vidéo les gens ont aimé il on
en redemande et je leur en ai redonné
pour voir ce que ça donne et c'est un
pied devant l'autre
je crois que c'est pour ça que tu alors
je parlais de chance avant tout pour
être le genre ouais de chance ouais ça
ça bon après nous en a on a pris ces
opportunités mais je pense que si demain
tu te dis comme ça tu te lève un matin
en disant j'ai envie de créer une chaîne
youtube
tu peux aussi réfléchir en amont
apprendre à se rendre à tourner et à
dire un jour ça y est maintenant je me
sens prêt je vais poster des vidéos ça
40e' pas que ça va marcher mais tu peux
construire un projet qu'il ya fort à
parier que si ça marche ce sera pas du
tout la chose pour laquelle tu t'étais
lancé à la base qui va devenir
ouais c'est bien par le choeur de ta
chaîne et bien sûr ses bons mots je vous
invite à continuer ses discussions en
privé à l'extérieur si vous voulez merci
à tous nos panélistes
et bon tracks
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]